Thank you very much. My name is Tiner.
I'm a Christian. I'm an employee in
hospitality management.
Uh
>> your name?
>> Dr. Zak. I'm Tiner. My name is Tiner.
>> Okay. I want to ask you about is
in the Bible mentioned
in John chapter 14 verse 6.
Jesus said unto him, "I am the way, the
truth, and the life. No man come cometh
unto the father but by me." What do you
think, sir? Thank you for the answer.
>> The sister who's a Christian, she has
asked a question.
She said that it's mentioned in the
Gospel of John chapter 14. And I did not
hear the verse what she said. I think in
verse number six.
>> Yes.
>> Because then what she I heard what she
said but the verse I could not get but I
know which verse she's referring to. She
said that mentioned in the gospel of
John chapter 14 verse number 6 that
Jesus Christ peace be upon him said that
I am the way and the truth.
No man cometh unto my unto my father but
through me.
She's asking what does it mean? And
there are many Christian missionaries
who claim that when Jesus Christ peace
be upon him made this statement, it's in
red letter. Red letter means if you take
a red letter Bible means everything what
Jesus Christ peace be upon him has said
it's mentioned in red. And this is in
red. And Jesus Christ peace be said that
I am the way, the truth and the life. No
man cometh unto my father but through
me. So doesn't it mean that Jesus Christ
peace be upon him is claiming divinity
and when I was in Malang and also in
solo
I told very clearly that if any
Christian can point out a single
unequivocal statement
from anywhere in the Bible where Jesus
Christ peace be upon himself says that I
am God or where he says worship me I'm
ready to accept Christianity
immediately. So this verse is said by
Jesus Christ peace be upon him. It's in
red gospel of John chapter 14 verse
number 6. So she's asking what does it
mean trying to say that doesn't it mean
that Jesus is claiming divinity in this
words nowhere did Jesus said I am God or
where he says worship me. But I will
give you the explanation for explanation
you have to go to verse number one.
So if you read the Bible gospel of John
chapter number 14 verse number one. If
you have the Bible you can open up. I'm
going to speak from my memory.
It's mentioned that Jesus Christ peace
be upon him says that in my father's
house
are many rooms.
I go there to prepare a place for you.
For it was not so, I would not have told
you.
I'm going there to prepare a place for
you
and you know where I go. So Thomas one
of the disciples says
we do not know where you go.
When Jesus Christ peace be upon himself
telling being a messenger of God
he's saying I'm going there to prepare a
place for you. In my
father's mansion are many houses and I'm
going to prepare a place for you. If you
believe in me, if you believe in him in
the father believe in me also. That
means if you believe in almighty God,
you believe in me also because I'm a
messenger of God and you know where I
go. So Thomas says we do not know where
thou goest.
Then he says I am the way, the truth and
the life. No man cometh unto the father
but through me.
So this statement
doesn't mean that Jesus is God. What
does it mean? That he was a messenger of
God. every messenger at his time he was
the way, the truth and the life. No man
came unto Almighty God but through the
teachings of the messenger. At the time
of Moses, Moses was the way, the truth,
and the life. No man came unto Almighty
God but through the teachings of Moses
peace be upon him. At the time of Jesus,
Jesus was the way, the truth, and the
life. No man came unto Almighty God but
through the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him. And we as Muslims we
believe that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him was one of the mightiest messengers
of God. Islam is the only non-Christian
faith which makes an article of faith to
believe in Jesus Christ peace be upon
him. No Muslim is a Muslim if he does
not believe in Jesus peace be upon him.
We believe that he was one of the
mightiest messengers of God. We believe
that he was born miraculously with many
modern day Christians today do not
believe. We believe that he healed those
born blind and lepers with God's
permission.
The Muslim and the Christians are going
together.
But
most of the Christians believe that
Jesus Christ peace be upon him claimed
divinity.
He claimed that he was God. They believe
he's son of God. That's the objection we
take. Therefore, I said if you can point
out a single unequivocal statement from
anywhere in the Bible where Jesus Christ
peace be upon himself says unequivocally
without any doubt, I am God. I worship
me. I am ready to accept Christianity.
So this sister is the words of a
messenger of God at the today
today who is the last messenger
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. So today
prophet Muhammad is the way the truth
and the life. No man cometh unto
Almighty God but through the teachings
of Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him.
So every messenger sister at his time he
was the way, the truth and the life. So
this statement of Jesus Christ is
correct. We believe in it because we
believe he was one of the mightiest
messengers of God. So when he made the
statement, we believe in that. But that
doesn't make him almighty God. Hope that
answers the question, sister.
>> Enough sir.
>> Sister, do you believe do you believe
that there's one God?
>> Yes or
>> how many gods do you believe in?
>> One, of course.
>> Do you believe Jesus is God or a
messenger of God?
>> Messenger of God.
>> Mashallah. Do you believe that Muhammad
is the messenger of God?
>> Yes, I believe too.
>> Mashallah. Sister,
if you believe in these three criteria,
these two criteria that there is one God
and no one worthy of worship and if you
believe that Jesus is God and also
believe that Prophet Muhammad is God,
then these two are the only requirement
that there's no God but Allah and that
Prophet Muhammad is a messenger for
anyone to become a Muslim. So according
to me you're a Muslim. Would you like to
accept Islam sister?
There are only two criteria.
If you say these two things, everything
else will come slowly slowly. But for
any human being to accept Islam, there
are minimum two criteria. One is to
believe that there's only one God and
don't believe anyone else is God. And
second is to believe that Prophet
Muhammad is God. That's what Prophet
Muhammad is a messenger of God. And we
also have to believe that Jesus is the
messenger of God. So since you believe
in all these three according to me you
are a Muslim. Would you like to accept
Islam?
>> I will thinking over about your
explanations. So anyway uh I will
>> was my was my explanation satisfactory
or not?
>> You you quoted to me from your Bible
Gospel of John 14 verse number 6. So was
my explanation correct or not?
>> Correct.
>> Mashallah. So and you also say that you
believe that Jesus is a messenger of
God. So we are going together.
So would you like to accept Islam
sister?
>> I accept Islam but I am still uh I'm
inconvenience with my way in Christian.
>> Sister there are many things which are
common in Islam and Christianity. Many
things for example
Jesus Christ peace be upon him he was
circumcised on the eth day. The Muslim
men they are circumcised. Most of the
Christians are not. It's mentioned if
you mean Christian means a person who
follows the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him. It's mentioned in the
Bible in the book of Ephesians 5 number
that do not be drunk with wine. It's
mentioned in the book of Proverbs 20
verse number one. Wine is a mocker.
Most the Muslims we don't have alcohol
but most of the Christians have. So if
Christian means person who follows the
teachings of Jesus Christ peace be upon
him. We Muslims are more Christian than
the Christian themselves.
It's mentioned in the Bible in the book
of Leviticus chapter chapter number 11
verse
number seven that thou shalt not have
the pig though it chews its scud its
cloven footed thou shalt not have its
flesh nor touch its carcass it's unclean
for you the same message repeated in the
book of Deuteronomy chapter number 14
verse number 8 that the pig The swine
though it has cloven foot it chews not
it cluds thou shall not have its flesh
nor touch its carcass. We Muslim don't
have pork but most of the Christians
have poke. So if Christian means a
person who follows the teachings of
Jesus Christ peace be upon him. We
Muslims are more Christian than the
Christian themselves.
So I'm not telling you to leave the
teachings of Jesus Christ peace. I'm
only requesting you follow the true
teachings of Jesus Christ. I follow all
the true teachings of Jesus Christ peace
be upon him.
So if Christian means person who follows
the teachings of Jesus Christ peace be
upon him. We Muslims are more Christian
than the Christian themselves. In Malang
two days back I gave a talk on Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in the
various world religious scriptures. And
I also give prophecies of prophet
Muhammad mentioned in the New Testament
and the Old Testament. Jesus Christ
peace be upon him said in the same
gospel you quoted same gospel chapter
number 14 same chapter verse number 16
Jesus Christ peace be upon him said
I will pray to the father to send a
comforter to you gospel of John 15:26
says and when the comforter will come
whom my father will say unto you he
shall glorify me gospel of John chapter
16 verse number 7 it is expedient for
you that I go away for if I go not away
The comforter shall not come for if I
depart shall I send him. This comforter
is no one but talking about Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam. It's further
mentioned in the gospel of John chapter
number 16 verse number 12 to 14. Jesus
Christ peace be upon him said I have
many things to say unto you but he
cannot bear them now for he when the
spirit of truth shall come he shall
guide you onto all throat. He shall not
speak of himself all that he shall he
speak. He shall glorify me. Now this
person that Jesus is talking about is
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam. So
if you're a true Christian, you have to
believe in prophet Muhammad which you're
doing. Mashallah.
So if you're doing that,
according to me, you're a Muslim.
Sister, if you believe there is one God,
you believe Prophet Muhammad is a
messenger of God, you believe Prophet
Jesus is a messenger of God, so what is
holding you back?
>> Anyway, I will consider about your
advice,
Dr. Zakin. Uh, I thinking over
>> You're most welcome. Do you don't take a
decision in a hurry, you read the Quran.
I ask the organizers to give you a
translation of the Quran in the language
you understand the best and you take it
take your time there's no hurry but let
it not be too late
>> we don't know how long will we live I
don't know whether I'm going to live
tomorrow or not
>> correct so take your time but don't take
too long
>> don't miss the bus and I pray to Allah
subhana wa ta'ala to guide you to the
thrill thank you sister
>> thank you sir